let's talk a little bit about social
democracy and populism today many of you
know that my political leanings are
toward social democracy social democracy
is of course a mixed economy it is a
capitalist system in the sense that you
have private ownership of businesses
some people are richer than others etc
but it is a capitalist system that is
actually well regulated it's used the
profits the fruits of capitalism are
used to ensure that nobody standard of
living falls too low to ensure everyone
has health care to ensure people have
access to education etc and this is a
system that sometimes has overlap with
populism and sometimes it doesn't and
what I want to talk about today are the
concerns I have that the move towards
populism over the last few years within
the left may lend itself to people being
bamboozled and to the perversion of
left-wing goals ideals and most
importantly of actually getting
left-wing stuff done increasingly we are
seeing populism become popularized and
there's a really interesting article in
the Journal of democracy called populism
and the decline of social democracy it's
by sherry Berman and Maria Segovia and
it argues that it's actually a danger to
democracy and to the left to see
populism replace social democracy and it
outlines some of the risks that are
implicit in that so let's start to dig
into it and the main concern I have with
populism is that it's too easy to use
populist rhetoric to bamboozle or trick
people because there is left wing
populism and right wing populism whereas
social democracy is decidedly left a
much clearer cut set of ideas and policy
prescriptions and much more
straightforward
as a means for achieving progressive
change to put it simply populism is a
political approach that wants to appeal
to ordinary people who feel that their
concerns their priorities are ignored or
disregarded by established elite groups
elite groups could be those in
government it could be those in
positions of power and corporations etc
rich people whatever so as you can
already see that is a broad enough
movement that that could be a left wing
or a right wing movement now there's an
academic expert on the issue of left
versus right wing populism his name is
Federico Finkelstein he is a fellow
Argentinean like me hilariously his dad
has known my dad for like decades from
Argentina we've interviewed Federico on
the show before and he has expertly
drawn the distinctions for us between
left-wing and right-wing populism but it
is very important to understand that
although there is no question of a huge
divide between left and right wing
populism the rhetoric is often very
similar and right wing ideology can be
cloaked and hidden as generic populism
in some very deceptive ways look at
Donald Trump's 2016 campaign that was a
right-wing populist campaign and here's
why it can be a great tool for deception
left-wing and right-wing populism both
take advantage of economic insecurity
and cultural anxiety of different kinds
to justify their own existence both left
and right wing populism often will point
to corruption and cronyism as a source
for what needs to be changed in our
societies not wrongly in principle both
left and right wing populism often push
this idea of us versus them but they are
very different us and very different
then right for someone like Bernie
Sanders us versus them is we instead of
I it's a politics of let's break up the
big banks it's the people against the
big banks let's deal with health
insurance companies let's deal with big
corporations and it's a good message
there's no question about it
for someone like Donald Trump us versus
them is us Americans instead of those
Mexican rapists and Middle Eastern
terrorists it's rich businessmen like me
who will fix your problems instead of
career politicians even if Trump ends up
hiring a lot of those same career
politicians it's trade deals that are
good for us instead of trade deals that
are good for China and Mexico except
when he passes those trade deals they're
terrible for American workers so indeed
when you look at the history of populism
populism is rooted in or comes from
totalitarianism that doesn't mean
populism is totalitarianism please don't
misquote me but populism can turn
authoritarian much more easily than
social democracy can look for example at
Venezuela where the shabbos regime now
Maduro has turned the rhetoric of
left-wing populism into authoritarianism
where the country cannot trust the
judiciary the country's resources have
been raped and pillaged for the benefit
of the few and the persistent paulla
poverty of the many you know the story
so what's my point my point is not that
left wing populism is bad in fact it's
not bad the point is that populism is
very easy to pervert and to trick people
with because the rhetoric of left and
right wing populism is often similar in
many ways and the line between true
progressive populism and centrist
populism and right-wing populism and
getting into authoritarianism it's often
blurry and gray and we're seeing that
with Donald Trump we've seen it in other
places as well now let's contrast this
with social democracy it's much more
difficult to pervert social democracy
it's much more difficult to trick people
with social democracy you could run on
social democracy and then just abandon
it but it would be very very obvious
there's really no way to do the rhetoric
of social democracy run on the policies
in social democracy and then slide into
a Thorat Arianism without people
noticing we're also seeing unfortunately
some on what we call the revolutionary
left actually fuel the shift
from social democracy into populism
which can be very quickly turned against
us and end up dividing the left very
badly and the risk is populism can go in
very undemocratic directions social
democracy really can't I mean ok we can
imagine some way in which it might but
for as long as it remains social
democracy it's not going to become
undemocratic and then let's go beyond
that not only do I think that replacing
social democracy with populism can be
dangerous to the Democratic
underpinnings of society I don't think
that it will really help the left long
term in the United States to move in the
direction of populism and away from
social democracy very often you'll hear
people on the Left say you know
right-wing populism has been on the
increase you see this in its
nationalistic implications
implementations in Europe you see it
under Donald Trump social democracy has
just failed it's been tough to get it
going in the United States let's adopt
our spin on populism but do it with
different prescriptions we blame the
problems on different actors of course
but the prescriptions that we often see
from left populism aren't really great
ones it's stuff like let's reclaim
nationalism and make it something good
for everyone for people of all races and
ethnicities will do nationalism but the
progressive way it hasn't worked and I
don't see any indication that it will
it's too easy to pervert that and for
bad actors to take advantage and you end
up in this revolutionary rabbit hole
that hurt Bernie in 2020 hated or liked
it it did not help Bernie Sanders in
2020 social democracy is specific
policies less wrapped up in an ideology
that can be perverted health care to
everyone let's figure out how to do it
paid parental and sick leave universal
early education increase the child tax
credit make it more affordable to go to
college and trade school reduce
incarceration legalize cannabis expand
government infrastructure spending tax
capital gains at a higher rate and
create some higher tax brackets it's
much more difficult to pervert that
stuff because it has less red or
Rick around it which becomes this fluid
squishy thing which is the case with
populism so my feeling right now is not
that populism is bad when it's actual
progressive populism my feeling is the
left has more to gain from social
democracy then it has to gain from the
rhetoric of left populism which so far
has not gone very far disagree with me
this is an important discussion to have
and when we think about you know
everybody's talking about why did Bernie
lose and who should be the torchbearers
of the progressive movement going
forward and there's a little bit of
discussion of you know maybe democratic
socialists wasn't a good term for Bernie
to adopt maybe the revolutionary
language wasn't useful but we actually
should go further and we should have a
deeper conversation about the move away
from social democracy from the
progressive left and towards the
rhetoric of populism even if not the
implementations of any policy I have I'm
open to having my mind changed this is
where I am right now I want to hear from
you we have a new document from the
Trump FEMA and the Trump CDC and it
predicts that by June 1st we may see
3,000 coronavirus deaths per day this is
the exact opposite of the prevailing
narrative from the Trump administration
the prevailing narrative is deaths
peaked in mid April at about 2,500 a day
they have been coming down and they will
continue to come down so we should start
reopening that's a big difference than
what FEMA and the CDC say which is by
June 1st the US alone will see 200,000
new cases a day and 3,000 deaths per day
how could there be such a conflict well
we're going to figure that out you all
know I have not been playing politics
with coronavirus from day one I have no
interest in playing politics with it I
hope that Donald Trump gets deaths down
to zero like that and I have no concerns
about the political implications of that
I want to see the deaths reduced right
away I hope Trump is right here and the
CDC and FEMA are wrong when we look at
the headline so far
cases have been sort of pretty steadily
around 25,000 new cases a day since the
first days of April we're testing about
three times as much now as we were a
month ago so if we keep finding 25,000
new cases a day but we triple testing
that implies that we are starting to be
on the tail end to some degree when we
look at deaths we saw what looks like a
peak in deaths around April 20th around
2,500 deaths a day although it's been
pretty up and down one would imagine one
would hope that deaths are going to keep
coming down not go back up to 3,000 a
day 25 days from now when presented with
these documents from FEMA and the CDC
the Trump administration so far has
simply said these are real documents but
they have not been presented to the
White House coronavirus task force we've
not evaluated them we are not in a
position to say that CDC and FEMA are
right now what would be a reason why we
would see the numbers seemingly coming
down but then go all the way back up
later this month sadly the answer is
something very basic the early hotspots
seem to be past their peak New York here
in Massachusetts we had only one point
three percent case growth yesterday New
Jersey but the places that did not have
an early increase an early breakout
outbreak they are increasingly on a
trajectory to become hot spots
that's what viral growth is when you
look at Florida for example bragging for
weeks and weeks that they're they're
fine they're good to reopen 615 new
cases in Florida on Sunday more than
eight or nine hundred yesterday in 14
days if that trajectory continues
Florida will be a hub of coronavirus in
the United States Georgia Georgia had
339 new cases on Sunday on Monday they
had more than double that if that
trajectory continues Georgia's in
trouble Louisiana very big increase from
Sunday to Monday so the numbers are
still small you're talking about
hundreds of cases a day not thousands or
tens of thousands but look at the
percentage increases and extrapolate out
1050
days those will be massive death zones
if that happens now if we get to 3,000
deaths per day around June first we are
gonna blow the hundred thousand person
death toll out of the water very very
quickly just ten days of three thousand
a day is 30k if we go from where we are
now to three thousand in the next 25
days that's another 50 thousand deaths
so if this estimate is correct by
mid-june we would be at a hundred and
fifty thousand deaths and we would just
be getting started I hope that this is
not accurate that would be a daily 911
what I fear the most
is that the Trump administration knows
that they failed and they are not going
to even address these new concerns from
CDC and FEMA that they're not even going
to try and they're just going to do
propaganda and economic messages from
here on out while shifting the blame for
the deaths to governor's I wish I could
say that that wasn't going to work but
unfortunately it may they're not beating
it they're not protecting Americans but
what they have shown they can do
effectively is shift blame and distract
and now say listen we did our part we're
now doing the economic stuff these
governors aren't testing enough these
governors aren't making the right
decisions these governors haven't
secured PPE it's on them now I hope it
doesn't work I hope this death toll
doesn't even happen but this is what CDC
and FEMA are now predicting let me know
what you think check out the reports
check out the papers and let me know on
Twitter at D Pakman also very exciting
in what is phase one of creating a daily
written digest of the David Pakman show
we have switched our newsletter to a
service called sub stack it's totally
free you can sign up at david pakman.com
or on our website if you go to david
pakman.com in the upper right where it
says like keep in touch get on the
newsletter that also will put you on
this new service for now we are just
doing our mailing list over on sub stack
but starting next week and the week
after it's going to be expanded into
like a daily written
digest of the David Pakman show
completely free signup we'll take a
quick break and be back after this the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world's famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are phyllis
dal-gu ono and jordi Levante phyllis and
Jordie thank you for your support
I so appreciate it you can get all of
the membership benefits in under a
minute
by signing up at join pakman.com also a
very special thank you to today's
sustainer of the day Thomas Farrell has
been a member for almost 5 years
imagine that longer than Trump has been
president thanks Thomas very much
appreciate your support
ok let's talk about antivirals and
coronavirus there's a big conversation
about what type of therapeutic treatment
might best work for coronavirus until we
have a vaccine there are all sorts of
different things being tested using
convalescent plasma to put the
antibodies of recovered people into the
bodies of those who are sick there are
all sorts of different types of
medications but one is antivirals so
Ramez aveer is an antiviral that is
currently the subject of a number of
random randomized controlled trials AVE
again also known as Philippa vert that's
a mouthful is another antiviral that's
being tested and what it is increasingly
looking like is that to get these
medications to work at their best
whatever the best will be we're probably
going to have to start administering
them much earlier in the disease
progression when the patient is less
sick and we're going to talk about why
in just a moment but just to sort of
orient the conversation there was this a
randomized controlled trial of Ramdas
vir we got the
results from it last week it was given
to patients already in serious enough
condition to be hospitalized about a
thousand people were part of this RCT
there was a placebo group and what the
study found was that the duration of the
virus was reduced by about 30% in the
group that received room des aveer
compared to the placebo group very good
that's something 30% is important we
know less about whether room des vir was
saving people who otherwise would have
died the results were not statistically
significant on the mortality but one
thing in general is that antivirals work
better when they're taken earlier and
this is it's not a problem per se but it
presents a challenge with room des vir
which I'll tell you about in a moment
but as a general rule antivirals work
better when they are taken earlier the
earlier the better
look at the flu influenza and Tamiflu
Tamiflu is recommended within 48 hours
of onset not if you've had it for days
not if you're so serious from the flu
that you have to be in the hospital
that's considered too late for Tamiflu
to work at its best ideally you start
Tamiflu within 12 hours of starting a
flu symptoms if not you want to start it
within 24 hours if not absolutely you
want to be on Tamiflu within 48 hours
and the reason why is inherent in how
antivirals work antivirals don't come in
and destroy the virus or kill the virus
so to speak antivirals prevent the virus
from replicating when we talk about
viral growth we're talking about not
only the spread of cases but you're in
imagine that you're in you know you have
two viral cells in your body they
replicate and become 4 and then 8 and 16
and 32 I think you sort of get the idea
what the antiviral does is it prevents
the virus from continuing to replicate
while the body can fight the virus the
longer you wait the larger the viral
load in the body when you introduce the
antiviral that's why you want to start
it earlier and that's why Ramdev severe
may were
significantly better if we were giving
it to people earlier what's the problem
with that well the problem with room des
aveer & coronavirus is that REM des
aveer is an intravenous therapy it's
given at a hospital for people who are
not only well into the disease but sick
enough to already be hospitalized
there's also potentially room reservoir
supply issues but it would be very
difficult to give you know how do you
you can't give everybody your room des
aver pill as soon as they test positive
for coronavirus there's also a limited
supply of hospital equipment to be doing
the IV infusions you need staff in order
to give IV medication there's not room
at hospitals to give everybody room des
vir intravenously as soon as they test
positive so this of course is all
assuming that it worked but these are
the conversations we're now having about
antivirals so the upside is that because
antivirals tend to work better when
given earlier the study that said from
des aveer shortened disease by 30% we
may be able to do way better than that
sick patients can do better with it but
early in the disease it may actually do
even more for people who have corona
virus the downside is an IV drug is
start it's tough to start giving to so
many people and since it's done in a
hospital setting we don't have the space
nor the resources nor the staffing to
give everybody room desert vir when they
test positive maybe if the supply is
increased you could give everybody in
high-risk groups the medication if it
continues to prove effective and
meanwhile we're continuing to have other
room desert vir trials it's been opened
up for emergency use by the FDA and
additionally we're also testing coletta
Caleta is a combination of two HIV drugs
Ave again is also being tested that's
another antiviral so that's the latest
but a growing conversation is maybe the
antivirals have to start earlier and
thus may be much more effective
hopefully there will be tests done of
that sooner than later hey this is
really interesting there's a few
Republican governors who have been
ignoring if not completely abandoning
Donald Trump
when it comes to dealing with the virus
in their states and their popularity has
absolutely exploded I'm talking mostly
about Ohio Republican Governor Mike
DeWine he's done a pretty good job of
handling coronavirus from day one
although more recently there are some
concerns about the policies he's rolling
out but he's mostly been following
health experts and not Donald Trump and
his popularity has soared we also have
been looking at how Maryland Republican
governor Larry Hogan has been dealing
with the virus and then our own governor
here in Massachusetts Charlie Baker a
Republican as well has been doing a
pretty good job and the reason that we
care about this is that the November of
2020 elections are in many ways
referendums that's the Ritz not
referenda I looked it up referendums on
Donald Trump when we look at the Senate
race in North Carolina with Republican
Thom Tillis or we look at martha
mcsalley
in Arizona or you look at Susan Collins
in Maine these are in large part
adjudications of the Trump regime and so
far it's not going particularly well for
those Republicans many Republicans have
been afraid of contradicting or crossing
Donald Trump because they're afraid it
might be bad for their local and state
races Trump might target me it could be
really really bad but what we're seeing
is that Ohio Republican Governor Mike
DeWine has absolutely split from Trump
and he is hugely benefiting from it in
terms of approval in terms of popularity
and this may be a signal for 2020 six
months away we can't say for sure but it
may be a signal what did Mike DeWine do
Mike DeWine lock down Ohio early before
other Republicans took it seriously
before Donald Trump was even taking it
seriously he's been doing regular
briefings that are actually fact-based
and they attract Democrats and
Republicans in Ohio and even nationally
people are watching these much like
Andrew Cuomo's briefings conservative
activists and business leaders have been
pressuring DeWine to do what Trump wants
start reopening do all this stuff and
DeWine just hasn't done it and he's been
listening to the health experts he also
came out in favor of a mail-in primary
late last month Trump has been viciously
opposed
mail-in voting and then more recently
this week DeWine has started to loosen
up some of the guidelines as businesses
can start opening masks are recommended
6 feet separation is recommended for
workers and customers and for a while
before this 30 or more Republicans in
the state legislature were demanding
that DeWine open everything right away
and he didn't do it
splitting with Trump and his approval on
coronavirus is 85% his trustworthiness
rating is 89% on coronavirus you don't
get those numbers with just Republicans
he's taking testing seriously he says
they're going to roughly triple testing
by the end of the month in Ohio from
7,000 a day to 20,000 a day and what's
interesting is that when we look at
Maryland and Massachusetts Republican
governors in blue states you kind of
have to as a Republican governor follow
what your liberal state legislators want
you to do Massachusetts has a Republican
governor and Charlie Baker but a very
left legislature and a relatively left
voting public so it's not surprising
that Charlie Baker is doing more what
our state wants rather than what Trump
wants but Ohio it's certainly a
battleground state but it's not a
left-wing stronghold of any kind so you
might imagine that what Mike DeWine has
done in abandoning Trump would be far
more risky but it has worked here in
Massachusetts Charlie Baker former CEO
of a big health insurance company I
didn't vote for him I'm not looking to
have more and more governors be former
CEOs of health insurance companies but
Charlie Baker knows how to delegate he
knows how to trust experts and he knows
how to look at data remember that dr.
Burke's laughably claimed that Trump
looks at data and makes decisions by
assimilating the information we all knew
it was BS what we want to see is
governor's actually do what DeWine has
been doing to some degree with Charlie
Baker and Hogan have been doing I'm
hopeful that as a result on May 18th
here in Massachusetts Charlie Baker will
be able to announce some loosening of
certain guidelines if the numbers keep
improving yesterday here in
Massachusetts we had only 1.4
percent case growth that's really low we
had a week of about three percent daily
case growth that's really not bad
so competence is important ideology is
less important here armed protesters
aside for the most part we've seen
people across the country approve of
competence even across party lines
Massachusetts voters overwhelmingly
pleased with the Republican Charlie
Baker despite being a blue state Ohio
voters Democrats and Republicans nearly
90 percent approval on a coronavirus
trustworthiness for the Republican
governor who has abandoned the doctrine
of Donald Trump again this may be a big
signal for how November of 2020 may go
hopefully we don't know we've gotta
count every single vote we have to cast
every ballot but that is the upside to
what we are seeing will have continued
coverage of this on the David Pakman
show
Instagram page at David Pakman show
follow me while you're there at David
Pakman to the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him welcome back to the
David Pakman show we are in a
hundred-year global pandemic and our
president is dramatically miss handling
it so I do want to keep you apprised as
to what he's been up to for the last 72
or so hours Donald Trump spent the
weekend at Camp David did a Fox News a
virtual Town Hall on Sunday night and
then he basically took yesterday off if
you look at Donald Trump's schedule from
Monday you find nothing on it and yet
yesterday was a really big day in a
sense we are fighting coronavirus we
learned of documents from the CDC and
FEMA told you about the documents
earlier they predict that we will spike
to 3,000 American deaths a day by June
first
hopefully not true but certainly
something to be taken very seriously we
found out states are rapidly running out
of unemployment money we found out that
states without enough social distancing
are starting to see large spikes in
cases on a percentage basis the numbers
may still be relatively small but
percentage-wise you are seeing some
times the case growth double from one
day to the next so we learned last week
that even when Trump does do work he
often is showing up at noon after
watching TV for five to seven hours a
day and sending out outrageous tweets
yesterday was a clear schedule except
for nearly 24 hours of Rage tweeting 6
a.m. to 1 a.m. okay I mean we're talking
about 19 hours of tweeting here all day
and night spent tweeting outrageous
attacks and untruth starting with
attacks on the press bright and early
saying quote con cast as he calls
Comcast
should open up a long-overdue Florida
cold case against psycho Joe Scarborough
I know him in crazy Myka well used them
beautifully in the last election dumped
them nicely and we'll stayed on the
record that he is nuts besides bad
ratings so attack on MSNBC attack on two
specific journalists media people Joe
Scarborough and Mika Brzezinski three
attacks it's like 6:30 in the morning
then Trump goes directly into talking
about his coronavirus ratings another
obsession saying quote getting great
reviews
finally for how well we are handling the
pandemic especially our strong
production of desperately needed
ventilators the building of field
hospitals and beds and soon the great
things we are doing on testing people
are really working well together
understand that 1200 people died on
Sunday another bunch died yesterday and
Trump is tweeting about reviews ratings
and getting credit this is a very sick
person this is an acutely unwell
individual Trump bragging then about
something which actually has been a huge
accomplishment forum which is one of the
main reasons that it's an emergency to
remove him in November which is judges
Donald Trump tweeted yesterday
Republicans love the biggest tax cuts
rebuilt military choice for vets which
was an Obama program by the way saving
Second Amendment and many other things
my administration has done but what they
love beyond all else is 252 so far
federal judges not including two great
Supreme Court justices a big record
Trump is Right Trump in in collusion
with Mitch McConnell have put in place
judges hundreds of judges who will
decide law and cases for your children
and grandchildren in some cases that is
how long they are going to be in power
he is right about this one and he must
be stopped then Trump attacking
California saying Mexico is sadly
experiencing very big virus problems and
now California get this doesn't want
people coming over the southern border
classic they are so lucky that I am
their president border is very tight and
the wall is rapidly being built so to
date to this point of the day he's
attacked MSNBC Joe Scarborough Mika
Brzezinski and California as well as
bragging about ratings
then Trump again bragging about testing
a favorite topic and if Trump is talking
about testing you know he's lying he
said quote by Congress not wanting the
special five-minute testing apparatus
they are saying that they are not
essential in any event we have great
testing capacity and have performed 6.5
million tests which is more than every
country in the world combined remember
we have the receipts the United States
is currently 41st in testing per capita
globally
we're behind Canada but we're ahead of
Belarus we have 331 million people
testing 6 million means that after two
months of this we've only tested 2% of
the population
what matters is our testing rate not the
number of tests we are 41st in the world
our death rate on the other hand is the
14th highest death rate in the world
don't take my word for it go look up the
numbers then later last night Trump
attacking MSNBC again but also CNN
tweeting MS DNC and fake news CNN are
going wild trying to protect China and
then this was really late last night it
was like 1:00 a.m. but it's so insane
I'm going to count it Trump very
triggered by a new political ad against
him with a multi tweet rant get a load
of this Trump saying this is this is
raged from a president in the middle of
the night it is very acutely unwell it's
a sign of Trump being ill saying quote a
group of RINO Republicans who failed too
badly 12 years ago then again eight
years ago and then got badly beaten by
me a political first time or four years
ago have copied no imagination the
concept of an ad from Ronald Reagan
morning in America doing everything
possible to get even for all of their
many failures you see these loser types
don't care about 252 new federal judges
two great Supreme Court justices a
rebuilt military a protected Second
Amendment biggest-ever tax and
regulation cuts and much more I didn't
use any of them because they don't know
how to win and their so-called Lincoln
project is a disgrace to Honest Abe I
don't know what Kellyanne did to her
deranged loser of a husband moon face
but it must have been really bad John
Weaver lost big for Kasich to me crazed
Rick Wilson who's been on this show lost
for Evan McMuffin McMullen to me Steve
Schmidt and Reid Galvan lost for John
McCain Romney's campaign manager lost to
Big O and Jennifer horn got thrown out
of the New Hampshire Republican Party
they're all losers but Abe Lincoln
Republican is all smiles the
unintelligent eligible rantings of a
lunatic a triggered lunatic so it's a
day with nothing scheduled for Donald
Trump after his weekend at Camp David
riddled with nonsense on Twitter during
which he attacked MSNBC CNN Joe
Scarborough Mika Brzezinski California
some Republicans Kellyanne Conway's
husband George Conway Republican
strategists Rick Wilson Steve Schmidt
Evan McMullen Mitt Romney's campaign
manager whose name he doesn't know and
Jennifer horn while bragging about his
coronavirus ratings and lying about
coronavirus testing this was just Monday
this was just Monday he also spent the
weekend rage tweeting with all sorts of
different claims including that
journalist Nicole Wallace was thrown off
of the view quote like a dog like a dog
that is the President of the United
States
thanks to sixty something million
Americans we must act in November I want
to show you a cartoonish video of a
trump official talking out of both sides
of his mouth and then I want to have a
serious conversation and actually trying
to talk about facts this is video of
Donald Trump Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo he went or Pompeo at some column
he went on ABC's this week over the
weekend with Martha
and during 30 seconds this is 30 seconds
he said yes coronavirus was man-made
no coronavirus was not man-made this is
the same guy this is the same day this
is the same interview this is the same
32 second segment completely incoherent
take a look at this it was man-made or
genetically modified but the best
experts so far seem to think it was
man-made have no reason to disbelieve
that at this point your your office of
the DNI says the consensus the
scientific consensus was not man-made or
genetically modified that's right I I
agree with that yeah I say I've seen
their analysis I've seen the summary
that you saw that was released publicly
I have no reason to doubt that that is
accurate
now I have no reason to disbelieve it
was man-made and my office is correct
that it's not man-made that is direct
conflict okay
you if you haven't been following this
Donald Trump and others have been
talking about whether coronavirus
instead of simply coming from bats
jumping to humans and then spreading if
it might have been a project of a level
4 biosafety laboratory in Wuhan China
and could have escaped because of a
mistake or maybe it was even released
deliberately like a bio weapon now there
are some fringe conspiracy theories that
insist that it was a deliberately
released man-made bio weapon that's I
mean that I'm not even gonna take that
seriously because there's no evidence of
that there have been some reports that
have jumped to relatively mainstream
corporate media which say it's being
looked at not whether it was man-made
but whether it was naturally occurring
but was being studied in the lab and
through an accident came out of the lab
okay
now I just want to make sure we're clear
on the possibilities we're talking about
and the ones that we are not so the
possibilities are this came from bats
and was transmitted in public through
natural means it came from bats was
being studied in this lab and was
accidentally released it came from bats
was studied in the lab and
was deliberately released it was
completely man-made but released
accidentally and then of course it was
completely man-made and released on
purpose as a bio weapon I'm only talking
about scenarios 1 & 2 which is if this
was being studied at this lab it was
released as an accident due to a mistake
the reason we are even having this
conversation is because there actually
have been some reports saying that this
is being looked at countless scientific
sources have already identified that it
is of natural origin that wouldn't
preclude it from having been studied at
this Wuhan lab and that's the reason
that we're bringing it out now what is a
biosafety level 4 lab anyway what we're
talking about is the Wuhan Institute of
virology this has been around since 2015
biosafety level 4 is when you were
working with easily transmitted
transmissible pathogens which can often
be transmitted via aerosol and which can
cause human death if a human is infected
often there would be no treatment or
vaccination if a human were to be
infected that's the level lab that they
have in Wuhan and there's a whole bunch
of other technical requirements if you
are level 4 so my position is before we
know for sure at this point it appears
that this is a naturally occurring
corona virus that came originally from
bats transmitted in public I'm open to
the idea that it may have been a
pathogen being researched in this lab if
we have evidence of that then we'll take
it more seriously as of right now I
don't believe that that was the case I
don't believe it was a bio weapon or
released on purpose but here's the
serious thing to consider okay if this
was something being researched in this
Corona in this Wuhan lab in China and it
was released accidentally it changes
nothing of Donald Trump's response to
the corona virus if it was completely
naturally transmitted the United States
in South Korea had their first cases
within hours of each other
South Korea handled it properly and the
United States did not
South Korea's death rate is
five people per million the u.s. death
rate is 210 people per million
you didn't miss here that our death rate
per population is 42 times that of South
Korea's so if this was mishandled at the
Wuhan lab and accidentally released that
must be researched that must be dealt
with and within China there are already
fears of a backlash like the ones seen
because of the Tiananmen Square incident
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
if that's the case there will be
backlash we all know that but it doesn't
make a difference in terms of evaluating
Trump's handling if it spread at a Wuhan
wet market Trump's response was terrible
if it came accidentally being released
from a Wuhan level for biosafety lab
Trump's response was still terrible it's
a very important thing that we not allow
the story about the source to distract
from our federal government's failed
response and from Donald Trump's
constant lies and attacks and smears as
a result of the virus we'll follow the
story
we'll take it where it leads us it does
nothing to make Donald Trump's response
anything but completely abysmal the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear don't miss
the bumper stickers to david pakman.com
forward slash gear the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
okay I'm here to tell you that a FoxNews
propagandist was right about something
but I am not telling you this to suggest
that this is a good person overall I'm
merely telling you every once in a while
the right does something so depraved
that even the worst of the worst
right-wing clown propagandists say this
is too much for me and it's a bad idea
and I'm talking about Fox News host Sean
Hannity Sean Hannity came out against
the outrageous armed protesters who have
been showing up with long guns and
handguns demanding states open
businesses and stop the coronavirus
public health measures that actual
doctors and public health officials have
determined are necessary let's take a
look at the clip from Hannity's program
down policies Michigan now I don't like
this part in Michigan I'm the number-one
supporter of radio and television that I
know of First Amendment and the Second
Amendment now no one is a bigger
defender of the Second Amendment than
yours truly everyone is the right to
protest protect themselves and try to
get the country open this with the
militia look here and these long guns no
show of force is dangerous that puts our
police at risk and by the way your
message will never be heard whoever you
people are no one should be attempting
to intimidate officials with a show of
force and god forbid something happens
then they're gonna go after all of us
law-abiding Second Amendment people I've
been carrying a I had up and carry
permit my whole life all right so he's
right I mean these armed protesters are
outrageous and it's dangerous and it's a
bad idea and Hannity has sort of
stumbled across the right position the
way a drunken guide a bar sometimes
stumbles back to their car before
driving drunk and crashing the vehicle
Hannity also has personal reasons like
he doesn't want the focus being on his
guns which he thinks it might be if
these nuts keep showing up with rifles
to state capitals around the country and
actor John Cusack actually made a
similar analogy he tweeted quote now not
interesting like a blackout drunk
slurring an apology after he crashed
into innocent people
he's a deranged pathological liar
enabler for a death cult nothing he says
has any adult human value now the I
generally agree but I think that there
is some value here one reason that this
is more than just a broken clock being
right once or twice a day is we know
Hannity has a huge real-world influence
on his audience a couple weeks ago we
found a we saw study that found that
people who watch Hannity as a primary
news source over Tucker Carlson and
other Fox News hosts the Hannity
Watchers are more likely to have gotten
coronavirus realistically because
Hannity was more against the lock downs
and downplayed the seriousness of the
virus earlier on his viewers saw that
and were encouraged to participate in
riskier behavior which made them more
likely to catch the virus so this
actually does affect people and the
point is that this is something when you
think about the role that sean hannity
has for his audience he's seen as like a
demigod by many of his viewers and if he
says the armed protesters don't make
sense this is too much it doesn't make
him a good person doesn't make him write
about anything else that he said but it
actually might mean someone one of his
viewers decides not to show up with a
long gun and we're all better off for it
we're all better off in every sense but
let me step back for a second I'm gonna
be perfectly frank with you here
I actually share Sean Hannity's
frustration with the protesters but I
also share the frustration of the
protesters I don't own guns I'm not
showing up to protest and I don't think
that the governors are the people we
should be protesting but I am outraged
and frustrated and saddened that what
we've been doing hasn't worked because
there's been no proper federal
coordination of a functional national
plan to deal with the virus so I'm with
the protesters in that I believe what
we've done has been worse for the
economy than it had to be but we don't
want to blame the governors for that we
need to be blaming Donald Trump's
administration the process should have
been on day one
a confirmed case that was January 20 the
Trump administration should have
immediately developed a working test
like South Korea did it wouldn't be
reasonable to expect that Trump would
shut things down when we had like 15
cases but remember that March 5th we
already had 221 cases in the United
States on March 5th Trump should have
come out and said let's do a coordinated
50-state shut down what we saw then
happening in China remember March 5
China had 80,000 cases and we had 200
that should have been enough when you
look at Italy on March 5th Italy already
had 4,000 cases on March 5th so we knew
how quickly it could spread in other
countries as well if on March 5 Trump
had said we're shutting it down
I need all 50 governors to do this with
me we're gonna do this for you know we
wouldn't have known at the time how long
but today is May 5th right we would be
60 days in to a federally coordinated
shut down the spread would have been cut
dramatically we wouldn't now have New
York and Massachusetts going down while
Georgia Florida and Texas are exploding
right we could actually have coordinated
this from the top and really be looking
at reopening now instead we're in a
situation where CDC and FEMA believe we
might be at 3,000 deaths a day by June
1st
Italy's cases are way down Spain's cases
are way down France's are way down South
Korea you know they've managed to keep
this to a couple of hundred deaths total
and we still have one to two thousand
deaths a day and States are opening
prematurely and cases are spiking so my
point is this if you want me to join the
protesters in saying this was mishandled
this didn't need to be this bad for the
economy I'm right there with you but
protesting governor's with guns is not
the right answer the right answer is
hold the people accountable who did the
wrong thing the federal coordination
failed us those who should be held
accountable are in Washington DC and of
course there are governors also acting
irresponsibly by wildly opening up or
never closing let's hold them
accountable now and let's hold
accountable in November as well hey I
think you'll find this hilariously
compelling Donald Trump as many of you
know has been accused of varying degrees
of sexual assault by a variety of women
and girls the number depending on how
you categorized them could be 12 it
could be 26 depends on where you draw
the line in terms of assault
Donald Trump has versus just harassment
to be clear Donald Trump has done
everything possible to shut these women
up he's hired high-priced lawyers he's
used payoffs of six figures in
combination with non-disclosure
agreements he's intimidated and
threatened women the entire thing Joe
Biden is also accused of sexual assault
by a woman most recently known as Tara
Reid I guess is the way I would say it
Joe Biden has asked that a file search
take place for her name in a number of
different files to see if there's a
record of this allegation from 1993 so
Donald Trump's daughter-in-law Larry
Trump an advisor to the 20/20 campaign
if you can believe that goes on Fox
News's judge Jeanine Pirro show and says
with a straight face if you were
innocent you would do anything possible
to clear your name including opening up
files irony is dead my friends take a
look at this video well I would think if
if you were being accused of something
and you were totally innocent you would
go to any lengths possible judge to try
and clear your name
including allowing people to open up
files like that and make sure you turned
over every single leaf to prove your
innocence
and make sure that people understood
that these charges were false and that
you did nothing wrong so apply what she
says to Donald Trump if Trump is
innocent he would do anything possible
to open the files to prove his innocence
except Trump paid to close the files as
usual the rules apply to everyone but
Trump himself there is a whole long list
of Donald Trump's accusers to whom this
strategy could be applied and yet it's
not it's the opposite not opening files
paying to keep files closed using
non-disclosure agreements to shut women
up every tactic you can imagine now if
judge Dunedin pier
were a serious journalist or even just a
serious commentator who wants to be
taken seriously
she should have immediately said to
Larry Trump why didn't Donald Trump do
that when it came to his 26 accusers why
hasn't Donald Trump opened the files on
anything or released women from
non-disclosures but Judge Jeanine is not
a serious person but remember that Lara
Trump's audience is Trump himself and
the Fox News crowd they don't care about
the hypocrisy they don't care about the
double standard and when presented with
the allegations against Trump they don't
care they are not reachable we've
learned that over the last four years
they're hypocrites and full of it but it
doesn't matter when your own followers
won't hold you to account why even
bother being consistent or telling the
truth there's no reason to and while
we're at it this applies to Donald
Trump's taxes as well remember oh yeah I
plan to release them well now I'm under
audit so I'll released them when I'm not
it's been four years guys it's been five
years I think since he started talking
about whether he would release those tax
returns he's not going to be held
accountable by his supporters either so
it's up to up to us to do it in November
I've got a voicemail for you today that
I suspect I will have viewers and
listeners who will not like this
voicemail and it is a caller speaking
some difficult truths to a sliver or a
slice of the left let's take a listen to
it progressive media is really risking
jumping the shark right now they're
covering stories like the George Bush
story and they seem to not understand
that people who do wrong things in the
past can occasionally still be
correcting statements they made and
they're also covering the story with Joe
Biden saying that we told you so Bernie
Sanders would beat the president no he
wouldn't Bernie Sanders couldn't even
win the Democratic nomination and it
wasn't the DNC's fault this time the
people did not like Bernie Sanders they
like Joe by.ya okay so let's listen
deal with that second issue first I've
already discussed the the Bernie Abidin
thing you know to assume that Bernie
obviously would defeat Trump in November
but Biden won't ignores essentially all
of the facts that we have including that
Bernie lost the Democratic primary by
millions of votes and that that number
may climb as more primaries are done via
mail-in ballot I don't think we need to
address that again on the issue of the
bush story what the caller is referring
to is that over the weekend George W
Bush put out a three-minute video where
he says the corona virus is serious it's
not the time for partisanship we need to
come together etc it's a completely
reasonable and accurate message it
doesn't mean Bush was right to go into
Iraq it doesn't mean Bush was right with
the torture it doesn't mean anything
about Bush other then he was right about
that and he's more sensible than Trump
on this issue and I covered this
yesterday
and I had already been getting attacked
on Twitter for it over the weekend and I
got attacked again for rehabilitating
the reputation of a war criminal etc etc
and what I've realized if I've had it
sort of an epiphany over the last ten
days and I'm gonna tell you what it is
right now what we've got a couple
minutes here before we wrap the show so
I'll tell you what it is
I always tended to just do the show the
way I want to do it and do the stories I
want to do and so on and so forth but
every once in a while a little bit of
calculation would enter in where I might
say I need to moderate my language here
or there or whatever because I risk
getting a certain reaction from my
audience which I would seek to to avoid
I'm not really paying any more attention
to that because no matter what I do that
backlash is going to exist in case in
point yesterday I literally said during
my segment about hey George W Bush was
right about this one thing right this
should not be a partisan thing the
coronavirus we've got to come together
Trump is wrong on it
I said twice in the segment Bush is a
war criminal I called the statement a
completely unremarkable milquetoast
statement and yet it still shows us how
whacked Donald Trump is on this and
every other
that he can't even put out a normal
statement one time which George W Bush
was able to do didn't matter
didn't call them a war criminal twice in
the segment and people are saying David
you are ignoring the fact that this
guy's a war criminal and real bit
rehabilitating his image I called him a
war criminal twice during the segment so
what I've clearly realized is when
people say David you should cover this
or you shouldn't cover that or here's
the position you have to do it actually
doesn't matter it all if people have
determined that I'm the enemy if they
want to be mad at me they're going to be
regardless of what I say if I cover a
story if I don't cover or whatever so if
you see any change in the show over the
next couple of weeks
other than the fact that we've extended
the show an additional 10% every day the
show is longer now which is beautiful
the fantastic thing you will see that I
will be paying even I was paying 8%
attention before call it to what I
expected the reactions to be to how I
take on issues that's going down to zero
some people will like it some people
will not but alas such as light we've
got a great bonus show for you today
become a member at join pakman.com do
not miss today's bonus show it will be a
particularly good one
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]